it's time for drew's news your daily
tune-up at the good news garage from
vroom and today i've got two fantastic
mechanics under that news hood with me
she's a best-selling author of fearless
journalists and a hero of mine lisa live
oh yeah
and he helps me make the good news
engine go every day of the week it's
rossy ross
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a really big deal
thank you i appreciate it i'm so excited
to be here um i've always been
um a good news junkie i mean i am like i
do my civic duty i watch that news every
single day
i mean for me i
i i wanted to be on tv as a kid and i
i'll tell you why so my parents got a
divorce when i was seven and they were
working all the time and the tv was
always on in my house we didn't have a
lot of money and so i thought well if i
can somehow get a job on tv
maybe one day i can have a better life
um but no one looked like me on tv you
know like my favorite show was the brady
bunch and i didn't look like jan or
marsha or anything but there was connie
chung and do you all remember connie oh
core
love honey chung yes i mean connie chung
just symbolized all that was intelligent
and beautiful and graceful and i i she
allowed me
to
know that i could i could do this
because she was the only asian person on
a national stage and if you ask any
asian journalist of my uh generation i'm
sure they will all say that connie chung
was their inspiration because she was
the only one and think about this lisa
like the next generation
they see you
you know and they're looking at you and
they're going to emulate what you're
doing now don't make me cry
it's so cool
i think that's the best point that we
have made so far absolutely you're so
excited i appreciate that um well we are
so thrilled you're here we do like to
get into some headlines so are you ready
let's do it all right first step we've
got a fascinating fact that we just
learned about uh
well another hero of all of ours um and
someone you worked intimately with oprah
uh people reports that she recently went
on hoda's podcast to reveal that when it
comes to friends the magic number is
three oprah says she doesn't have a lot
of friends it's just gail maria
schreiber and her trainer bob greene
um lisa what do you think about this
magic three number with your colleague
oprah well it's funny because i did work
for oprah for a long time and it was
hard to imagine being friends with her
because i just i was so in awe of her
and i just i would just stare at her and
she would probably not want to be
friends with someone like me because i
was creeping her out yeah all of my
friends
um i have more than three
uh but they are 40 30 and 20 years in
the making so they're really i i'm into
old friends and i feel like i don't
often get to make new friends
necessarily what about you rossi well
except you by the way you're my i'm but
i've known you for a long time too sorta
yeah right but we became like boom right
when we need each other like velcro i
know
i looked i think this might be the first
time i've ever felt sorry for oprah i
think i think i i understand the value
of keeping a tight circle but a girl
anything do you need a friend honey i'll
take you out to happy hour my treat
oprah and i mean that from the bottom of
my heart
i count my friend they are so
important to me and if i committed a
crime i could think of 22 people off the
top of my head i would call who would
lie to the authorities for me and you
need that you're lucky you're lucky
um my friends would be like again
by the way
seriously like real talk though all
jokes aside i can't imagine
the places you have put yourself have
you ever truly been
nervous in over your head or like whoa
what is next
yes
really you know before i even started at
the view i worked for a show called
channel 1 news which was seen in schools
across the country and we were sent to
cover some crazy things i mean i covered
the civil war in afghanistan in 1994 and
i covered drug wars throughout south
america
and i would say the scariest moment for
me was when we were rappelling out of
um narco helicopters
with the narco uh police into
cocaine-infested laboratories um in the
jungles and getting fired upon that was
a kind of scary moment
maybe i need to work a little harder
because
i mean i was scared one time when i
grabbed like a pashmina at macy's
that's like the most dangerous thing
i've ever
encountered that is scary actually scary
but i did get that pashmina thank you
very much you know who you are in all
transparency we have put ross in some
very perilous situations um so many
carbs so many carbs i forced you to eat
um all right lisa will you please take
the next story well next up we are
turning into some sports news and it's
it's always a heartbreaker when an
athlete is sidelined by injury but mets
star pitcher noah sundergaard has found
an incredible way to make time count the
new york times reports noah also known
as thor
put down the baseball and picked up some
books and started his own book club he
invited fans to join via text and each
month they get a new title and take the
conversation even deeper noah interviews
authors on instagram live met's fans say
it helps them appreciate their picture
in a new way and some say they're
reading books they never would have
picked up
so are you guys in a in a book club i'm
not in a book club but i really love the
books that he's putting out there
because i always think when athletes
talk about mental health these are
infallible
incredible you know humans with
extraordinary capacity
i love when tough guys come out and show
their softer side this is a great
gateway in that might not have the
stigma of your week or you're this it's
like
even strongest people we know it's
totally hot too totally right i mean
yeah guys who you know in those like
tight picture pants and also well read i
that's like a perfect combination dude
yeah that's
[Applause]
what we call
that's what we call a home run
well this story i really loved um
because it spoke to me and made me feel
a little less alone um here is a
question would you rather life be calm
or exciting
what would you say ross i wonder i'm
gonna go with calm now
wow because back in the day it's like
give me a little excitement but now give
me some elastic and some netflix i'm
exhausted
[Applause]
and cnn actually reports that a new
study found people
overwhelmingly prefer calm they surveyed
people in 116 countries and 72 percent
wanted calm and 16 wanted exciting with
10
wanting a mix of both so i'd like to
pull the audience right now grab your
poles everybody
um and let's ask you guys with a show of
green
for calm
being your desired lifestyle and red for
a hot exciting lifestyle okay here we go
oh it's kind of a mix
interesting
oh i like you're just right in the
middle ma'am
i might have to ask you what's the
middle all about and what does that mean
to you
i am a single mother so i'd like a calm
life
with my children but then i also want an
exciting life when i don't have them
and they're with their dad
[Music]
you